what's up you guys time for the movie
retrospective
got a good one kind of a forgotten
canadian film
it actually this one was actually
literally forgotten like it came out
back in 1974
and then it was sort of i don't even
know if it was lost most of the things
that it was like lost until somebody
found it in the mid-1990s and
re-released it which is kind of
fascinating
because this is actually a pretty this
movie was actually like a lot better
than i was expecting i have to say i'll
have to see it again i liked it but i i
got so relaxed in the middle of it i
fell asleep suck it up
yeah so most of the movie i was watching
it i kept hearing it was like like while
it was yeah but it was really good it
was basically about ed geen and it was
pretty close you know yeah in general
there was some artistic license we'll
get into that they're trying to make it
a horror movie which you know [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was a horror movie anyway
yeah but uh it was it was good and the
guy that played it jenny was recognized
him because man that's a dude that
played la bay
and uh christine chris john carpenter's
christian john carter and i was like
that sure is man that's that dude and he
plays basically plays a dude that's
supposed to be at gate ezra cobb is the
name of the character but it's that game
yeah he addresses the same and
everything yeah a lot of the same [ __ ]
happens i mean it's not verbatim but
it's
in general a little bit like psycho
yeah well i mean psycho was based on it
uh texas chainsaw massacre was based on
a game silence of the lambs was a little
bit based on uh on ed gein
this one at least at the time that this
came out in 1974
was the most accurate even though as i
said they did take licenses license with
some stuff
um which i'll get into like what they
changed and stuff but yeah so it's
usually just uh under the title deranged
also known as deranged confessions of a
necrophile which is a little bit of a
misnomer because one ed gein didn't
wouldn't ever cop to necrophilia uh and
two there is actually really no
necrophilia in this movie yeah uh so
yeah but the working titleist was
necromania
now interestingly okay so this had two
directors as i said this was canadian
they actually shot this in ontario even
though i guess it's supposed to be
wisconsin but i don't think they really
say like where it really happened
so this was co-directed by a guy named
jeff gillen and a guy named alan ormsby
now alan ormsby if you don't know that
name
he actually started out as a makeup
artist and was like a really big deal
like makeup artist he was also a
director actor and a screenwriter
he actually got his start
writing doing the makeup effects for and
starring in children shouldn't play with
dead things have we reviewed that yet we
should
uh that was one of the first movies when
i was a kid yeah it's it's not great but
there's something about it that i really
really like but i had forgotten that
children shouldn't play with dead things
was actually directed by bob clark the
same guy that did black christmas
and a christmas story and porkies this
is so this is better than movie than
that this is way better than children
should play with dead things uh honestly
it really is this movie is as good as
chainsaw the first chainsaw massacre i
think it's different but it's different
yeah we're a little more depressing you
know he's living with dead bodies and
[ __ ] and it's almost like it's like a
black comedy too i want to say like and
i think it's deliberately a black comedy
whereas texas chainsaw massacre
not really so funny i guess it had like
sort of funny stuff in it but the acting
is pretty good yeah i think good yeah
the guy that plays ezra cobb you know ed
gein
uh robert's blossom
and i saw him
and he's in there and he's talking and
i'm like god i know that voice it's like
i'm that voice is like so familiar i
know i've seen something a lot of times
that that dude was in and then like two
minutes later it hit me that's la bay
from christine yeah now i feel like uh
yeah for the john carpenter one from
1983. now i feel like most people though
will recognize him as uh old man marley
in home alone he was like the guy with
the shovel
yeah so i kind of feel like most people
remember him from that but he was in i
looked at his wikipedia page he died in
2011 sadly but uh he was working up
until the late 90s and he was also in uh
close encounters of the third kind he
was an escape from alcatraz he was in
the last temptation of christ so he was
in a [ __ ] ton of stuff he's also a poet
and he did like a bunch of theater and a
bunch of tv so he was in a [ __ ] ton of
stuff uh but i think
please correct me if i'm wrong but
deranged might be his only leading role
he was usually like a character actor
he's great in it he's good he's [ __ ]
fantastic in this he is so good it's
like i don't he embodies and i don't
know what that says about him as a
person but he like embodies this [ __ ]
role you like he's real creepy yeah real
creepy you buy it oh big time okay yeah
everything about this he acts pretty
much exactly like ed gein acted but it
doesn't seem like he's acting no he
nails it he's [ __ ] great
you kind of lose track
that this is i kind of did but that's
not a game because he it he does come
across like ed gain yeah you know like
super awkward like almost a little bit
sympathetic because he was kind of
stupid
not stupid but just kind of really
really sheltered and like didn't really
know much of anything and kind of
pitiful yeah it started to get real
interesting and then i fell asleep but
it did anything with the movie i was
trashed but you know i was trashed but i
was enjoying the movie i was going oh
man this is a good one it's so good good
one yeah and all of a sudden he started
dating this girl and everything and
she was talking about oh yeah i talked
to my dad and he passed away and he's
going oh yeah because he talked to his
mom he's got his mom in bed
the body the dead body you know what i
mean i was like oh this is going to turn
out bad
[Laughter]
they were having some kind of seance and
i was creeping out and i just [ __ ]
[ __ ] left my body yeah cause i was
talking to you because i was like making
jokes like the movie because you know
man like i do but then like he started
snoring and i was like oh okay well
there's that yeah
it just started to get real interesting
and i [ __ ] slipped away i gotta go
back and finish it and honestly this i
will say that like the start of this is
a little bit slow yeah um but and one
thing
i kind of i watched a few other people's
reviews of this and one thing that seems
to be kind of uh divisive about it is
whether people liked the narrator
character or not i liked it i did too
yeah but some people were like yeah i
didn't really need that you could have
just like showed it the narrator comes
in the camera like he's doing a damn
like during the scene like here's what's
going on
yeah i liked that i liked it yeah but
like some people were like yeah we could
have done without that but i didn't mind
it this is a very low budget movie it's
like it's 200 000 yeah very low budget
but there's something about that kind of
adds to the creepiness and it and the
narrator stepping in
adds some it kind of adds some cheese in
it
that takes some of the [ __ ]
i want to say it's
it makes a little it makes it better
because you're not really you know
you're watching a production it's kind
of theatrical of a certain way you know
and when you see that
there's no way to describe it it sets
the tone of the movie you're not taking
the movie a hundred percent seriously
which allows you to enjoy it more and
you kind of take it you actually take it
more seriously that they there's no way
to describe it it's
yeah so whether or not you like the
narrator character or not because
honestly he just comes in at the
beginning like doing kind of like a
little prologue like this movie is based
on real events and you know babies if
it's not for the squeamish and blah blah
we tried to like make it as accurate as
possible which is not entirely true but
we'll get into that a little bit um but
then like throughout the rest of the
movie like there'll be a scene and like
there'll be some [ __ ] going on like you
know uh ed will be or ezra will be there
with his mom and his mom's dead or
whatever and then like the narrator will
kind of like come in and be like blah
blah blah blah i can explain what i was
trying to explain now okay what it is is
he comes in
and when he when the narration comes in
it really it kind of reinforces to you
the audience that they are telling you a
story yeah okay and that what you're
seeing is a theatrical
rendition of a story
that really happened so your imagination
kind of piles on top of what you're
seeing going yeah i know that's not a
real dead body
but imagine that that was really
happening in this real story that
they're telling you about so there's
kind of like two things go at least
that's the way it almost had to me you
made you take it a little bit more
seriously
yeah i kind of took it in the same uh in
the same vein as something like in
search of right where you had like a
narrator like you know the leonard nimoy
and you see it in a re-enactment and
you're seeing a reenactment going on
behind it and he's like talking about
like what's happening like updating you
on some [ __ ] you're seeing a reenactment
yeah but then you're imagining what it
really would have been like it would
have been even worse than what they're
showing you yeah so it's it's effective
i thought it was very effective i did as
well but like i said you know your
mileage may vary because i know some
people liked it and some people didn't
like it that was kind of one divisive
thing pretty much one thing everybody
agreed upon was robert's blossom the guy
that plays ezra cobb slash ed gein was
amazing i mean he's worth watching this
just yeah honestly he's [ __ ] skin
crawling like he's just so good he just
embodies that role so much also [ __ ]
great the effects for a 200 000 movie
yeah the corpses and [ __ ] like that look
great you know you know why that is
because the co-director and the
screenwriter alan ormsby won was like a
big uh big deal uh special effects guy
and guess who his
assistant on this movie was some little
nobody named tom [ __ ] sabine now
interestingly if you look at tom
savini's wikipedia page
it says that his first job like his
career filmography thing starts in 1978
with george ramirez martin
however he was an assistant to alan
ormsby on this and on youtube if you
look up deranged making of or something
like that there's like an hour-long
documentary that i guess came out in
like the 90s like it's pretty shitty
quality like vhs quality but some parts
of it they have all this like super 8
or 16 millimeter uh footage of them like
making the movie like behind the scenes
[ __ ] and tom savini like narrates a
bunch of it like saying oh yeah i
remember how we did this that the other
thing so he absolutely did work on this
movie and you can see him in a couple of
the shots like setting up some of the
stuff he wasn't the main special effects
guy but he was uh an assistant on it and
that's kind of why even though this
movie was like a nothing budget
the corpse effects look great i mean
those corpses look really really tom
savini i think is the first guy that
actually got blood right
yeah from what i can remember now the
blood doesn't look great in this one it
still looks like red tempera paint yeah
that was the problem with old school
blood yeah it looked like [ __ ] yellow
orangish red ketchup yeah but to the
naked eye if you were there on scene it
looks red but there's something with the
color processing when it after the the
film was processed it come out kind of
orange looking if i remember correctly
the savini figured out how to get it to
look good i think it's green yeah like
adding some green i think it added green
to it it almost would look black
yeah you wanted to look kind of brown or
like maroon right it didn't look red to
the naked eye
but then when it went through color
processing
the film you know
it would come out looking blood red
and i think he was only got to figure
that out and then his his formula i
think got ripped off and everybody
started using that
yeah i mean i didn't think he cared
about that he was just kind of him or i
don't know if it was him or um
uh rick baker or dick smith i think was
his uh was one guy that he was uh real
influenced by but i think though those
guys like figured all that out and then
like after he just let it go
because i kind of feel like the special
effects guys they kind of like share all
their [ __ ] yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
though you guys
don't know what color it is like in uh
alien 2 you know aliens those you know
the the smart rifles and the pulse
rifles that the marines had they looked
like they were black and green but that
was color processing and in um
in uh
if you look at the actual
guns
uh
the the ones that they used in the movie
they're brown
do you know that
yeah they're like purplish brown purple
is brown and black well that's what i
mean when the thing about it is that
reality and how things turn out on film
looks very different looks and it
depends well do you and i'm not a
filmmaker but i'm a graphic designer and
some of the same [ __ ] applies um because
it has to do with like the film stock it
has to do in you know with print it has
to do with what kind of paper is it what
kind of ink is it what kind of you know
the color is going to look wildly
different depending on what the media i
was very surprised i was looking at the
pulse rifles and [ __ ] on the screen they
look green and black but they're not
they're brown they're kind of a maroon
yeah maroon and black but they knew they
knew that they made them that color
because they knew they'd turn out
looking green
once they filmed this process they've
got it they got it all figured out yeah
well like i said that's why they have
all these big crews like all that
technical expertise because it's not
just you can't just point a camera at
something and have it turn out the way
you want it it's like there's a million
there's a million things you have to
like think of a million considerations
especially back then video is probably
not as bad
but yeah but it film was a chemical
process yeah and it's just not not
accurate yeah you never know how the
[ __ ] is gonna turn out
uh but yeah so as i said so the special
effects in this are like punching way
above their weight for such a cheap ass
movie yeah now i will note and i didn't
know this was when i was watching it
this is actually on amazon prime if you
have amazon prime it's free on there at
the moment
um
when i was watching it uh i think it's
84 minutes 82 minutes something like
that
now when i was watching a documentary
about it they brought up this one scene
they said oh the scene where ezra cobb
cuts off the top of somebody's head and
scoops their brain and eyeballs out i
was like wait i don't remember seeing
that turns out that that scene was cut
out uh by the mpaa or was you know the
npa said you have to cut that scene out
to get an r rating because it was like
two it was gruesome so it's not in the
movie that's on amazon prime but if you
look on youtube and that documentary
that i talked about earlier that hour
long one that shows that entire scene uh
it's kind of shitty quality but you can
still see and it's a shame they didn't
leave it in there uh maybe at some point
if they could restore it they
they could restore it and maybe the
blu-ray one will have it because there
is like a really funny scene where he
just saws off the table it's a good
movie it was like scooping it around
this would be worth having on blu-ray
from what i from i think it would be too
it's like this there's just something
really really as i said i was expecting
all i knew about this movie i had never
seen it before as i said it was pretty
much lost from shortly after it was
released in 1974 and then somebody found
it in somebody's [ __ ] garage or
something like that in the 90s um so it
was lost all that time i feel like
people kind of forgot about it it's
canadian so a lot of people kind of
forget about a lot of canadians as well
yeah well it's that kind of thing i mean
if it's not like black christmas or
something like that everybody's just
kind of like canadian movies what even
though there's a really lot of good
canadian horror movies there really are
but uh but this is and this is one of
them yeah my bloody valentine my bloody
valentine yeah that's also a great one
yeah there's a lot of good ones uh the
gate or not the gate um yeah i think the
gate yeah the one with the key with the
hole in the ground yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh that's also really good so there's a
lot um and actually if you if you
subscribe to brandon tennold's channel
because he's canadian so every day every
year he does can exploitation like one
month and he'll do like all canadian
horror movies which is really funny but
yeah so this is canadian so i kind of
feel like it was forgotten so i didn't
see it at the time i had heard the name
of it and i vaguely knew that it was
sort of based on ed gein and that's all
i knew i was expecting this to be
terrible
um but maybe fun terrible but when i was
watching it i was like this is actually
really good i would have loved it it's
actually really good and i think as i
said the effects really elevate it the
acting really elevates it not all the
actors are great like some of them are
kind of amateurish but
because the guy playing the ed gein
character is so good
and most of the time it's focused on him
it really really kind of elevates this
way beyond just some trashy like b movie
it's kind of movie that back in the 80s
you know uh my friends would have said
dude man we got this like in
illicit [ __ ] video yeah from the
video store there's only one copy you're
not supposed to be seeing this [ __ ] it's
not
it's a lost movie
you pop that a [ __ ] in there and you're
like oh and it's eerie
everything i saw was very eerie like i
said i want to finish it it's a good
quality movie um it's not an expensive
movie it's [ __ ] dirt cheap but i
would say
on par with like what was it basket case
kind of like that that um kind of
production but better the tone tone was
a little more uh
credible i guess you could say in a way
um the acting better a lot better um
yeah definitely
probably more like on the lines of texas
chainsaw mask or the first one
and it's weird because this came out the
same year as texas chainsaw massacre
either a couple months before or a
couple months after
and the strange thing about it is that
i don't think it was ripping off texas
chainsaw massacre because they would
have probably had to be making them
around the same time
but this has a scene it's not exactly
like the one from texas chain so i'm
asking her but it's similar you know
like the dinner scene and texas chainsaw
massacre where she's like strapped to
the thing they there's a scene like that
in here
but i was like well who ripped off who
then or did anybody rip off anybody
maybe it was just maybe just because it
was based on
the same thing it was based on ed gein
even though obviously texas chainsaw
massacre was wildly different it just
took a couple of things from ed gain
this is a lot closer even though it adds
some stuff that ed gaine didn't really
yeah this one kind of like in some ways
kind of reminds me of
henry's portrait of a serial killer
kinda except this is like that is
serious yeah this one has like dark
humor yeah uh con
tones not quite as silly as evil dead
but
almost you know what i mean
it's you just got to see it um
it's hard to place it
yeah it's a really strange tone but it
was the tone that i was like really into
it was good because i kind of like this
sort of like dark humor all right so
let's do like a little thing of the plot
and then we'll say well we'll say where
it deviated from what ed gain really did
so what you have at the beginning
is you have uh ezra cobb
who is taking care of his elderly mom
and just like in ed gaines case the mom
was
uh kept telling him like oh women are
[ __ ] and blah blah blah
and she's dying so she dies
and
he can't even like he can't deal with it
and he seems not normal at the beginning
but he doesn't seem like crazy until
after she dies
yeah he just seems like kind of a
harmless sort of not idiot but just a
very simple he's a simple man that's
about like what gain was yeah yeah
so his mom dies and then at the funeral
you can tell that he's sort of starting
to teeter over into maybe like delusion
because
uh you know his only two friends the
only other two people that come to the
funeral they're just like oh you know
your mother looks so nice like in the
coffin or whatever which is a weird
thing that everybody always says at
funerals i don't know why um she's like
she's just sleeping yeah she just looks
like she's sleeping and he's like well
she is she is just sleeping
you know what i mean you're like oh here
it goes yeah but it actually does take a
year
um while he's in the house and he seems
to be having trouble
he kind of like acts like she's just
gone like on a trip like he keeps her
room the same it keeps the stove on in
there he lays her clothes out and he's
like yes when are you gonna come back
blah blah blah and then he starts doing
like the norman bates thing where he's
like talking in her voice why don't you
come get me you let me down here in the
grave goddammit it's so dark and cold
down here yeah that's why i was saying
it's kind of like normal yeah it's like
it's pretty it's funny but it's also
kind of like creepy at the same time and
so he's like i'm coming to get you mama
so like it takes a year and he goes and
like digs her up and the funny thing is
when he goes to dig her up at first like
he opens the coffin and he thinks that
she looks the same as she did when she
died
and he's like oh yay like she looks you
look just the same and blah blah and
then like reality intervenes yeah and
she's all [ __ ] blue and [ __ ] up
yeah the cops pull him over when he's
got her in the front seat
the cops knew him yeah he made an excuse
that he had killed some kind of like a
hog a hog or something and it was in the
front they didn't really check though
they're like man [ __ ] clean that car
out trying to let him go yeah he's just
i butchered a hog yeah
and then he said and then after the
cobble and then after the cop leaves
he's like i'm sorry i've called you a
hog mama yeah yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] up so uh so yeah so he
keeps mom at home and like talks to her
and apparently she talks back to him now
his neighbors get concerned because
they're like well you're living in that
house by yourself because obviously i
don't know he has his mom's corpse in
there and so they're like well you need
a lady to take care of you you need to
get married and start dating and stuff
like that and he's obviously like a
virgin and doesn't know anything about
anything but he remembers that before
his mom died his mom said
the only woman that she ever trusted was
because women are [ __ ] and just full
of disease and sin and everything it's
like the only woman she ever trusted was
this woman like a friend of hers named
maureen selby you know and do you know
why mom trusted her because she's fat
that's right only fat was
only fat
because she's fat i guess he's like yeah
okay he buys that makes sense okay that
makes complete total sense she goes out
to go get him a fair girl so he decides
he's gonna go see her at which point
they start like she's kind of like oh
hey like you're the friends with the mom
and you know she so she like lets him in
and
at first like he says he let something
slip that he talks to his mom and she's
just kind of like yeah you talked to
your mom she's like i talk to my dead
husband too everybody makes fun of me
like she doesn't realize that he means
no i literally have the corpse of my mom
in there that i talk to so she's like we
should you know what we should do we
should have a seance yeah and like you
i'll talk to you and like we'll talk to
the dead i'll talk to harold or whatever
the [ __ ] her husband's name was and
we'll talk to your mom and it'll be like
really cool and then and then so she
this part this this is uh this is
completely fictional by the way
obviously like
but it's really funny and so yeah so
this little this little woman is like so
they're having a seance and she starts
channeling her dead husband's voice and
basically her dead husband is
saying to ezra
um hey you need to like put the dick the
dick in on my wife and that's okay with
my blessing
she's trying to talk away she's trying
to talk away to some dick
it's [ __ ] hilarious i was laughing
and that's about when i fell asleep oh
so you didn't see what happened after
that oh okay but that's uh
laughing and i [ __ ] felt [ __ ]
[ __ ] up maybe we should spoil it
but yeah so uh obviously that was a
fictional uh thing that woman was not
one of his victims
um that was his thinking though i think
but that was probably yeah so it's you
and after fat girls parts of it are like
fictionalized but not
yeah but not that much but this woman is
like a complete uh you know fabrication
so after that kind of whole situation
um you know he's killed a real person
so
now they kind of go more into the actual
ed gain story where he goes to this bar
tavern thing and he meets this
waitress who works there and develops
like a fixation on her now in the
movie she's called mary ransom
um that's not her real her real first
name was mary now interestingly though
in the movie they say to her it's like
that the bartender the narrator says uh
you know she works at this bar or
whatever and she's 34 years old but a
little bit over the hill and i was like
hey
34 is over the hill suddenly okay but
maybe but well no but maybe because in
real life uh that woman that worked at
the tavern was like in her 50s
so maybe that's what they meant but the
character what they specifically said
was 34 and then said that she was over
the hill and well a little bit over the
hill might have meant that she drank a
lot and she was ragged out they were
like rode hard put away wet i guess but
she didn't look that bad in the movies
she looks pretty good actually she
looked pretty foxy still
um i mean she looked like she was in her
30s but she didn't look like dudes
making the movie were probably in her
20s maybe maybe that's what it was man
she's an old bat but yeah i just thought
that was really funny but the but the
real victim that this is uh you know
that this is representing was actually
20 years older than that so maybe that's
where they're kind of getting that from
but yeah so he kind of gets fixated on
her
and
lures her back to her house because he
actually slashes her tires
and then is like there helpfully like oh
hey um i'll take you to a gas station
you know to get new tires and then he's
like oh no i have tires at my house and
i'll put them on for free
you know and she's just kind of doesn't
really want to do that but then he's
like no come on it'll be fine and then
he goes in the house and this is
actually the best scene in the movie i
think because
she's kind of like waiting for him out
in the truck and then he won't come out
and she's like honking the horn like
come on i want to go the [ __ ] home or
these tires and then finally like she's
just like [ __ ] it and she goes in the
house
at which point she sees
all of the corpses because uh ezra slash
ed has been real busy it's not just his
mom now he has like a whole bunch of
corpses in there and he's also made
himself
uh a leather face uh ensemble where it's
just kind of like where he has like a
face and it has like this long woman's
hair and he's wearing this like dress
and like a thing with like tits on it
and everything like that and it's
creepy it's like really like just the
whole scene where she comes in and like
just takes in this whole room and he's
just like sitting there with all these
other corpses it's creepy that's like
one of the best scenes in the movie i
think yeah so there's that and nobody's
really gotten down to nobody's really
gotten down to the bottom of [ __ ]
what ed gaines [ __ ] issue was
i mean because he certainly had one he
had all kinds of issues but he never
fessed up to any of them there weren't
any witnesses he just dug up a lot of
dead bodies and
tried to preserve skin and made a
woman's suit and you know all kinds of
weird made a belt out of nipples had a
box full of vaginas yeah he had and he
wasn't killing people at first he was
just digging them up
yeah he had some bowls made out of human
skulls and yeah he had stuff in the
garbage can uh but they don't
i don't know what he was doing i think
he was i think he was kind of a uh a
what do you call a transvestite
but instead of dressing up in women's
clothing he put on skin and clothing
well i think that's where they got the
silence of the ladies the buffalo bill
idea from but i don't think he was a
transsexual yeah it there's a
transvestite
like like ed wood
maybe yeah because like i said those are
two completely different things which
they kind of got into a little bit in
silence of the lambs because he's saying
he's not a real transvestite yeah or
he's not a real transsexual rather
because yeah that's not really the same
thing i think he was a transvestite yeah
and he was putting on his mom's clothes
and then he started putting on his mom's
skin and they started putting other
people's skin on but it didn't have
anything to do with him wanting to
become a woman it was just uh
it made him feel better somehow made him
feel like i don't know i think maybe it
was bringing his mom back to life yeah
maybe he was like personifying her which
like i said that was kind of like what
psycho was kind of getting at yeah yeah
so it might have been that i forgot to
mention that the reason in the movie
that he first started robbing graves was
because when he got his mom which ed
gaine never did that he didn't dig his
mom up but um he does in this movie but
when he dug her up she didn't look so
good obviously because she'd been in the
ground for a year and so he thought he
got the idea from one of his friends
talking about an obituary which he
didn't even know an obituary was that's
how sheltered he was and he's like you
mean they put it in the newspaper when
people die like right after their
funeral and he's like woo score and he
even says it out loud to them at the
table so even if you needed like like
parts you could just a head or something
like that you could just and they just
think he's joking but he's like no he's
totally serious and he can't understand
like why they think it's so funny and
it's just like so that's i don't know
that was like really funny to me but so
he started like robbing graves to like
fix up his mom like start patching her
up so she would look better and she's
like she's got little bits like stuck
all over like that but that's how he
started but yeah like it sort of went
because the thing about this is the the
movie kind of like compacts everything
into like a short period of time because
in real life
it was what like eight years or
something where he was doing it for a
long time yeah he didn't dig up his mom
did he no i think he was digging up the
other women as a substitute for the mom
though maybe he was afraid to dig up his
mom or she was too she had been dead for
too long when he when he came up with
the idea there was something there was
some reason why
it definitely had something to do with
his mom oh well yeah yeah because it
seemed like his whole life like
which is very common with serial killers
they always have really weird
relationships with their mom he's trying
to make a mom doll or something yeah i
think it definitely was but yeah so so
this victim like i said in the movie he
actually kills uh the woman the seance
woman and that's like was like his first
kill but that's not a real woman like
that's not um it doesn't have anything
to do with like one of his real victims
but the woman that works at the bar
that's like based on a real victim and
pretty much the same thing happens
although in the movie he like bashes her
in the head with this cane that he made
like out of a bone like a thigh bone um
in the in real life i think he shot her
and then cut her head off yeah in real
life he was doing weird things he'd kind
of like sexualized this whole thing
where it kind of got meshed in with
i guess sexual attraction it was
it was
he didn't have normal sexual sexuality
uh clearly yeah i think he was a virgin
i think he was too yeah and they kind of
persuade they don't say it out loud in
this movie but they kind of portray it
as he doesn't really all right no i
think he was trying to make some kind of
mom doll in real life and somehow him
dealing with all those body parts and
they weren't his mom but they would
somehow kind of got infused with some
kind of sexual making
belts out of nipples and stuff
which they think is some [ __ ] like that
i know that's crazy and that you know
what they don't really show this the
movie is like fairly graphic
um but they don't show they do show that
he makes things out of the bodies like i
said he has a cane made with a thigh
bone he has bowls made of skulls he has
uh like a violin that he made and he
said oh that's not cat gut you know what
i mean like he made the string out of
intestines or whatever and um so they
show that but it's not as gruesome as
maybe they would have nowadays in real
life he had a woman's face and he had it
made like a mask it was kind of hanging
up in front of a window remember that
yeah that's right they do show he adds
like a couple of faces yeah i think it
had lipstick on it and everything yeah
like i said there's some leather face
that's where it was crazy i mean ed gein
was so [ __ ] crazy that all of these
other all of these horror movies are
based on him there are so many i think
there was a movie that came out in
2011 or 2012 or something like that that
was just called ed gain or gain or
something and i'm assuming that that was
more accurate to like what actually
happened but when this came out in 1974
this was actually the most accurate edge
movie even though they again took some
artistic license yeah and actually i
don't think if i remember recall
correctly i don't think ed gained
qualified as a serial killer i don't
think he killed enough people did he it
was mostly digging up dead bodies i
think he only killed two i think he just
killed two two i mean but it was pretty
horrible enough and it's like
i mean the two that they knew was kind
of great nothing
sexual and and i think the feds said
that really to qualify you have to kill
three or more
um
but you know he was there on the edge he
was a weird [ __ ] i think they should
give him an honorary serial killer yeah
medal or whatever
he said well the motive wasn't quite
sexual
he was just a weird dude man [ __ ] and
he
they said in his trial
they showed him some photographs of he
had a body hung up in his uh when he was
working on it he had it hung up and they
show that in this movie because that was
like his last victim yeah which i was
gonna get to a little bit during his
little trial [ __ ] they confronted him
with the evidence and they said that he
looked at that picture for [ __ ]
forever and he said the expression on
his face was like he was seeing
something intensely beautiful he's and
he has to see more of the [ __ ]
photographs of it he's just reliving it
so he had he had somehow sexualized all
that
and he had kind of a thing and it's kind
of portrayed in this movie too where
he doesn't really
you can tell he's crazy because he
doesn't really seem to understand why
other people like he knows like when he
robs his mom's grave he knows like when
the cops pulled him over to hide it
right he knows enough to do that but
then later on
as i said when he's at the table and
they're talking about an obituary
they're talking about like an old
teacher of theirs that died and he's
like oh you mean they put that in the
paper when somebody dies it's like oh
well if you need parts and stuff like
he's just talking like it's a normal
thing to talk about and like everybody
just thinks it's so weird they just
think he's joking and then later on when
mary the bartender lady when she goes
missing and it's in the paper and his
neighbor says oh they'll never find that
girl and he's uh you know ed is there
ezra is there and he says oh you know
that she's not missing i've got her yeah
they probably and the guy's like what
are you talking about and he's like i've
got her i'm back at my place i've got
her and i got mom and i got mrs whatever
the teacher's name was and all that
they're just like whatever you're crazy
but he was
he was serious
but it's like they didn't so he didn't
really have any compunction all about it
he's like i've got her like they're just
the most casual [ __ ] thing in the
world based on memory you know it the
real person at ed was kind of like way
below average intelligence yeah he was
not um
an intelligent guy i think they said he
was just borderline uh mentally
handicapped
but people didn't take him seriously he
didn't think he was a threat
yeah you know and that's kind of how
he's portrayed in this like nobody
really he says [ __ ] out loud and like no
everybody just thinks he's kidding or
yeah or he's kind of dumb or something
he was borderline
real dumb yeah but
i can understand you know who who would
think of this
you know just it just kind of goes to
show you you can't let the dudes that
dumb [ __ ] just out on their own for
you know who haven't
been in that shelter he was kind of
feral
inside in some ways he really didn't
seem to have any issue
yeah and so
so the last killing in the movie which
is similar to what happened in real life
he targets
um his neighbors have like a teenage son
and the son has a girlfriend in the
movie her name's sally mae
and she's real young in the movie
obviously she's like a college student
in real life again she was in her 50s
but this is meant to be the same
character because she works in a
hardware store uh ed goes in there
and
i think in the movie they show him just
going in there like one day but uh i
think in real life it was like over two
days or whatever but he just goes in
there he shoots her takes her back to
the farm and hangs her up by her feet
and starts like cutting her like you
know like a [ __ ] cat in real life he
shot her around closing time yeah and
then took her out through the back they
thought the place had been robbed
yeah because it was like blood all over
yeah there was some blood but uh you
know now he took her they found they
found her quickly
yeah they're working on her it's well
it's because um and this is kind of a
little bit different to what they show
in the movie but uh in real life he
bought something like he bought some
antifreeze at the source so his um
uh you know his sale on the uh cash
registry he was the last one that had
bought something they said oh he was the
last one in the store so we got to go
out and check because he was the last
person to see her alive yada yada so and
then they found her and she was and he
was like still working on her which is
similar to what happens in this what
happens in this is like like i said the
girl the victim is actually young she's
in her 20s whereas in real life she's in
her 50s um but he shoots her and puts
her in the back of the truck but then
she i guess the bullet just grazed her
or whatever and then so she wakes up and
she like gets away for a little while
but then she falls into like a rabbit
trap or something then he finds her and
then he takes her back and he actually
doesn't buy this is really weird he
doesn't actually buy the antifreeze in
the he he brings it to the counter but
then she's like oh well you just want
the antifreeze he's like no i'm gonna
look around for a little while and then
he goes and like loads the gun and
shoots her with it but so his thing
isn't on the register but the only
reason that they know is because the
neighbor and the kid were in there when
he came in so they knew that he was like
the last guy that was in there so they
said we need to go out to the [ __ ]
thing because they find blood all over
the floor so it's similar to what
happened in real life but not exactly
but um but yeah so i mean if you have
any interest at all in ed gein
and you haven't seen this movie as i
said it does take some artistic license
with some of the stuff yeah but it's
good though but
it's way better than it really has any
right being yeah i was surprised um
because i was just expecting some
schlocky
like act but it was really i mean the
effects are [ __ ] great the corpses
and stuff look [ __ ] great um you know
the [ __ ] dude that plays ezra cobb
slash ed gein
awesome i can't believe this might be
this guy's only like i said starring
role so he was like a character actor
maybe he might have been had a starring
role in some other stuff too i guess i
mean you know this movie's like uh if
you were to go back in time before the
internet and see this in the year that
it came out would have blown your mind
because oh yeah that [ __ ] really
happened you know and you wouldn't have
really been able to pick apart
real very well the the original case and
how it's shown in the movie you just saw
the movie go yeah that was it that's how
it happened
yeah it's similar it's pretty much
similar it's pretty much it's kind of
like you know how the talent dreaded
sundown like that which was like the
about the phantom killer and it was like
had some different [ __ ] in it like
everyone's names were changed and they
did the thing with the trombone which
didn't really happen and stuff but other
than that it was fairly similar this one
adds an extra victim and makes the
victims younger and changes a couple of
the details but other than that this is
pretty oh and like i said has him take
his mom's body from the grave but that's
not a huge stretch because he did take a
bunch of that's pretty much he had
gained pretty much pretty much and
honestly
now that we're thinking about it texas
chainsaw massacre which came out in 1974
also loosely based on a gain actually
also started with this is based on a
true story even though
this movie deranged is way more accurate
to the ed gene case than texas chainsaw
massacre texas chainsaw massacre other
than the skin wearing and the house and
everything really didn't have much to do
with edging at all yeah um but
you know it's just yeah but this one is
obviously recognizable as ed gaines
because he even wears that yeah that
plaid yellow jacket and that hat they
pretty much capture the tone of his
personality this is that's yeah what he
was like
it didn't do all that stuff but he did a
lot of that stuff but they got the they
got the tone of his character that's
that's that's like he was like that yeah
pretty much i heard that i don't know if
this is true i heard that christopher
walken uh auditioned for that part for
the part of this movie that had been a
trip which had been really funny i
probably wouldn't have been as good i
don't think yeah i don't think i can
imagine now that i'm thinking about now
that i've seen it i don't think i could
imagine anybody other than that dude in
it because that dude he knows he [ __ ]
nails it i mean he's exactly like and
like i said you forget that he's acting
like even he has like these the weird
facial tics that he has and those freaky
like bright blue eyes like just the
facial expressions and the way he like
purses his lips and [ __ ] like that it's
[ __ ] it's incredible it's like really
really good it's crazy it's really good
crazy new england farm boy out of
nowhere [ __ ] doing this well it's
midwest yeah yeah it's wisconsin yeah
but yeah midwest yeah yeah but yeah i
mean so if you haven't seen deranged
from 1974
it's definitely worth watching there's
all kind of like
the this kind of like early roles for an
early kind of like crew stuff for like a
lot of really
famous like horror people like i said
like tom savini and stuff like that like
later on and it's definitely definitely
worth watching i i had a really good
time with this way better than i was
expecting and also like kind of a dark
comedy starts out a little bit slow
but
once he once his mom dies and he digs up
her body like it gets like way way way
better um but yeah so it's definitely
worth watching it's on amazon prime if
you have it you can watch it on there
for free don't know where else it is at
the moment but definitely check it out
or if you've seen it let us know what
you think about it in the comments and
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one bye
you